one night
i had my edibles in my drawer
and he stole one he's used to like a 70
milligram quad dose i eat the decadence
i didn't know you could be that high for
that long off of something that was that
small
that's what she said so he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's getting into
i go down into his room
i open the door
and he's shirtless
on his bed
doing this
[Laughter]
what are you doing man just trying to
figure something out
maybe i was trying to save the world
somehow you know what oh i'm pretty sure
you wouldn't understand
i was probably right i couldn't even
understand what i was trying to do let
alone someone who was sober oh i'm
pretty sure you wouldn't understand
i go why did you try me and he was like
okay was gonna sound crazy
and i go try me and he goes well the
first thing i need to know is
can you hear this
[Music]
i wish i could go back and relive this
moment just so i could have answers i
want answers too man
can you hear this
i said
i cannot he goes well then you can't
help me
okay
so his hand's been down this whole time
and i go to him i go hey man stop for a
second just and just talk to me and you
know when you're that high and you're
doing something this weird
for all he knows like he thinks he's
saving the world
probably what was playing and that i
could hear was the avengers theme song
i was doing something incredible with my
hands at that time did you steal one of
my edibles you i don't know what that is
i got an edible is a food with weeded he
goes oh that sounds delicious
i'm so high at this point obviously you
just have to play dumb
i'd like to try one of those someday i'm
like i don't bet you would oh you didn't
steal one of my animals he goes no i
know
i oh you didn't steal it you no i didn't
steal it and then i look down as trash
can and the [ __ ] rapper is right
there
i think what's that he goes oh i stole
it i stole your edible
and he goes i'm so glad you saw that
rapper i'm so high i can't fake it
anymore
so when i finally started talking to my
dad about me smoking weed and uh you
know me starting to like experiment
because i wasn't really a drinker in
high school and weed was a little easier
to get since we lived in california and
it's just been like medically legal and
all that um so when i told him that i
started smoking weed you know i started
confidently going on these walks at
night because well i knew i wasn't gonna
get questioned where i was because it
was we were good
um
and i remember just going all right i'm
going to 7-eleven and i would take the
long way around but you know i would and
i would know that by this time my dad's
already high in bed because if i'm going
on a walk to 7-eleven around 9 or 10 p.m
both him and my mom are in bed
getting ready to go to bed because you
know on a school night we shut down
around 10 p.m 11 p.m
and i would get texts on my walk to
7-eleven
just one word though brownie
rice krispie
skittles
cookie just like just seven or eight
things in a row and i would go and just
plan to buy a gatorade and a bag of
chips and a candy bar and i would come
back with three bags worth of crap from
7-eleven because high-ass mcgee in his
bed is just sitting there like this
going yeah i need all these snacks real
quick i want to be here for a while like
god that man it's ridiculous
thank you guys again for tuning in if
you enjoy the content uh please
leave a like leave a comment make sure
you're subscribed hit that notification
button so you know when all the new
videos drop so you guys can be first
ones to go out and see it and uh thank
you for tuning in again today i hope you
all have a great day and we'll uh we'll
see you next time
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]